Dr Umar man give me my five hundred
dollars back man I have the series
called giving strangers the inward pass
let's play that today
well I mean you guys already got it
I was like damn it'll be hilarious to
get Dr Umar to like react to it so you
get to get an interview from him you
have to like donate 500 to a school yeah
so I PayPal him and everything we're
we're emailing to set it up and then he
just ghosted me I was like I might as
well just troll him so he was in
Jacksonville so we flew to Jacksonville
I got a dashiki and he said through his
whole seminar and it's a show he is up
there doing like
[Music]
but then I was like damn it'll be funny
if like I show him my like white
girlfriends whenever I went up I was
like yo doctor Umar this is my girl he's
like oh he's a snow buddy lover get him
out of here it's nobody's seasoning like
just trolling him but Dr um please give
me my 500 back